hey there boys and girls it's your old
podcast pal Ralph here why don't you
check out the Ralph report that's my
Daily Show Monday through Friday you can
get an ear full of me and we have a
pretty good time plus if you're a
Hollywood Babylon fan and you subscribe
at the three or four star general levels
you can get the entire back catalog of
Hollywood Babylon the past decade of
babylon's for you to listen to at your
leisure plus the four star tier they get
to watch us record the show live once a
week plus there's a live stream events
all kinds of goodies why don't you go
check it out we're over there at patreon
go to patreon.com the Ralph report
that's
p-a-t-r-e-o-n-.com the Ralph report or
check us out at the ralphreport.com
it's time to babble the [__] on
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Hollywood Babylon
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
[Music]
welcome my friends to Hollywood Babylon
I'm Kevin smoke that's not the way we
start the [__] show it is Saturday
night at smodcast castle ladies and
gentlemen
so let's Babble the [__] out I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Ralph Garner hey
I'm just so money drunk from the auction
yeah
you done with your little yard sale can
we do the show now
for those listening at home and they
weren't involved before the show began
man we do auctions here before
everything that I hosted Spa Castle and
uh we sold a bunch of cool [__] could
not sell a pair of smodcast
sneakers to save my life didn't go for
it not even at smod Castle that's how I
should have marketed and [__] but we
sold literally I had a mall a box of
Mall Rats cards other than that though
what's that
the Mall Rats card somebody bought them
yeah when did that happen
when I left the stage
they were waiting for me to go away
by all means let's recap the yard sale
you left me alone with this bottle for
way too long before we started the show
I told rough I was like it'd be a half
an hour tops Jesus Christ if I had known
I would have brought some underwear from
the hotel
do you want to sell some underwear
tonight yes absolutely never never
washed
37 I hear 69.
do I owe someone anal is that what I
heard yes that's when I auctioned off
that's all the only news that traveled
upstairs was that I owe someone butt sex
yes at least a pinky up the ass anything
to support the arts for folks yeah
uh welcome kids uh to Hollywood Babylons
the second time we've ever done it at
smodcast Castle give it up for the guy
who traveled all the way from Hollywood
to Babylon with you Mr Brown [__]
Garmin oh thank you
then the other guy who traveled all the
way from [__] Hollywood to be here
tonight on the Wheels of Steel the guy
that [__] runs the show we just show
up Dr Josh Roush ladies and gentlemen
thank you doctor
me I live here so I'm always [__]
here yeah how are you been my friend
it's BYOB I'm not so good but uh
whatever it takes that bottle is kind of
empty [__] yeah I was working on it
upstairs so anything goes tonight
[__] day who put the gum up here I
don't know I found that I thought maybe
you left it behind you want to [__]
sell it yeah
you put it up here
save that for later
thank you man lavender
um boy oh boy kids we got some show for
you tonight man lovely to be here in
Atlantic Highlands right in the [__]
smog Castle
um normally when we do the show I gotta
drive to it today I just walk down the
stairs yeah yeah you usually drive to it
I had to fly to it
oh my God that's right I'm like a little
more effort a little bit you put in a
lot more my bad I'm happy to be back
East it's nice to be back on the east
coast once in a while absolutely
not quite home but it's close enough
close enough that's right you're a
Philadelphia kid I am I got Philly boys
in the house tonight I got
part of my crew my old crew is here
tonight is that right people used to
hang out with you yes my best friend
from Philly Tommy's here tonight
and uh his brother Danny and Eric and
Chris my crew from Philly's here when uh
did you guys hang out how old were you
uh in college we were College friends
college did getting any same sex
exploration [__] what's wrong with you
that's what happens in college I didn't
go but that's what I heard happens in
college
guys sit around and [__] daisy chain
thank you no man we were
we were uh just we're rolling deep yo
me and my crew is that what they did in
the 50s flying in Rock
50s [__]
um well [__] welcome to Ralph's
friends thanks for coming boys I
appreciate it good to see you
a little bit of the hometown you're
going hard with the liquor I'm going
hard with the liquid death yeah you are
that's water that's water right sounded
so much like an ad I'm sorry they don't
pay me [__] no oh speaking of that real
quickly we want to thank our sponsor
tonight manscapes.com [__] you you made
fun of me for selling [__] now you're
gonna sell some [__]
this is Corporate this is capitalism
fair enough man uh we want to thank the
good Folks at manscaped for sponsoring
tonight's episode of Hollywood Babylon
put it together for manscape yes
whether you trim your pubes or not I
would like to thank them we are heading
into smooth sack summer oh [__] is that
what it's called that's what they're
telling me yeah
you know it gets hot so you want to make
sure you get uh to get those balls nice
and smooth sure and scrotums all the way
yeah I wish there was manscaped around
when I was younger when I first started
manscaping
you chose to manscape oh yeah it was the
thing yeah why it was that request at
request what are your [__] College
Tommy Tommy asked me to trim down a
little bit yeah get that bush out of the
way I can't get to your balls fast
enough
no it was a young lady I was dating she
was like this would be much nicer if you
would uh you know trim up and you
buckled I didn't Buckle I was like I'm
in I had done worse things with her
so you didn't what did you use back uh
straight razor Sweeney Todd style and
[__] like this I used to make meat pies
out of my balls she did that's for sure
no I used to use scissors just like
scissors in the shower it was not a good
idea I slipped once and took about a
quarter inch of skin out of my scrotum
why man because I was not a good scissor
user obviously and so what you were
doing on the pubes at the top of your
dick or the a ball I was trimming my
balls
when you're using scissors around your
balls you never want to hear
something tells me it felt it before you
heard it man oh man yeah do you pull the
ball sack out like a bullfrog and then
do the trims or what uh with my balls I
just put them on a table or something
foreign
all good ideas for the folks at manscape
yes but now manscape takes care of that
for you you won't hear when you're using
manscape products instead you'll hear
that's right uh the performance package
4.0 with manscaped everything you need
to keep your balls summer
trimmed
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer see that's
what I needed I needed a trimmer this
thing's waterproof it's got a spotlight
so you can see all those hard to get
places I guess it makes sense to like
trim them during the summer during the
winter you want as much ball hair as
possible keep them warm and [__] but in
the summertime anything goes they throw
in crop preserver deodorant for your
balls yeah you need that in Jersey in
the summer yeah no [__] who knew that
was even a thing man ball smell
yeah as a matter of fact I don't know
everyone knows that I've never smelled
my own balls I have no idea I know yours
are long enough that you can you're like
when I throw them over myself
I get a whiff as they go by my head
uh they also threw in two free gifts
manscape boxers a shed travel bag and
you can look at the luxury nail grooming
kit as well because it is Barefoot and
flip-flop season fellas and men's feet
are [__] gross never forget that
um you can get all this 20 off plus free
shipping if you go to manscaped.com and
use our code Babble that's 20 off free
shipping if you use the code Babble so
welcome to smooth sack summer we thank
the good Folks at manscaped for
sponsoring this here podcast put it
together for the folks at Manchester
yeah
[Applause]
see if they'll go for it I um you bleed
a lot from the balls too I don't know if
I mentioned that speaking of bleeding
balls I went to see my mother this week
uh my mom the weirdest Segway segue but
I had to get there some now uh mom was
in the hospital has been in the hospital
for 10 [__] weeks I know she's been
struggling so but she got out and uh she
escaped uh
and I went down to Florida and uh
Wednesday I went down on uh Tuesday
Wednesday she got out and I went home
with her and stuff like that me and my
brother sprung her and uh she was so
delighted to be [__] home I put up a
little video because the whole time she
was in the hospital she kept talking
about her cat princess she got this cat
when my dad died we just came up on the
20-year anniversary of my dad's death
was on Thursday so it was a twofers get
Mom out of the hospital and then be
there for Dad's 20th anniversary because
she had a mass celebrated in his honor
she's still ostensibly Catholic the
whole time she was in the [__]
Hospital bro she would not stop talking
about her cat princess this is the cat
she got right after my dad died so the
cat is 20 [__] years old so it's on
borrowed time very much so so the whole
time my mom was in the hospital we kept
threatening the cat don't you [__]
die man she's living for you and [__]
and so mercifully the cat made it to my
mom get into the hospital cat's spry as
[__] you'd never know she was [__]
20. and when we got my mom home like the
cat literally like you know for the last
10 weeks me or my brother mother and
sister have been going to my mom's place
and feeding the cat and the cat doesn't
like any of us and she's always looking
passes for my mom when we got my mom
into the house it was the most adorable
[__] thing like all of a sudden my
cat clawed her face yeah
I was like piece of [__]
Mom's home
didn't happen quite that way
um the Cat my mom was calling for she's
like princess and the cat was like man
and came out looking for her and [__]
and I was so hoping that the cat like
wasn't like who are you and [__] and the
cat legit remembered my mom and was like
delighted to see her and [__] went
around her legs and my mom could barely
walk because she's been in a hospital
bed for 10 weeks right so I saw the
nightmare of the cat she loves tripping
her and [__] her falling two broken
hips exactly I'm like you piece of [__]
um but mercifully the cat didn't trip
her and stuff we eventually got my mom
to her church sat down immediately the
cat like jumps into her lap it was
[__] adorable and my mom was sitting
there kissing her and hugging her and
she was talking she was like I'm Never
Gonna Leave You Again [__] she didn't
even say to me my brother yeah
and she was like I love you so much
you're so bad my mom I was like and of
course natural I couldn't I go for the
lowest hanging fruit so I was like Ma I
had no idea how much you love [__] and
[__] she looked at me and she was
like this is Princess
it's like fair enough ma fair enough you
wouldn't appreciate Hollywood Babylon
that's the level of jokes that we
[__] tell it's all we got so on
Thursday was the anniversary of my dad's
death and as I said my mom had a mass
celebrated for him she has a church that
she goes to Blessed Sacrament like right
across the street from where she lives
and so uh she was like you're you're
going you have to go and I was like
naturally anything for for you and stuff
now thing I forgot I'm in a church in a
[__] dog's age I used to go to church
all the time I was an altar boy when I
was a kid uh then I made that movie
Dogma and I haven't really been welcomed
back in church ever since you really
haven't heard much from the Catholic
church since no no they never call
they're never like you should come back
we love you um but I said as I went to
church I was like I don't think I've
been in a church or gone to mass since
my kid was like baptized and my brother
corrected me he's like you came down and
went to mass with mom like one on Dad's
one year anniversary the one year
anniversary of his death and so I was
like wow it's been a red hot minute so
going in one of the first things I
noticed was like I had been an altar boy
from age seven till like uh 12th grade
even though I didn't go to a Catholic
High School I went to a public high
school and went to Henrietta and [__] uh
anytime I was at like mass and they
didn't have an altar boy you could jump
up on the Altar and [__] fit pitch in
because you missed the sex yes
that was the thing man there was no
altar boy it was an altar man like an oh
like a [__] guy who was as old as the
priest dressed like an altar boy and
[__] and I was like what the [__] this
all about and my brother goes boys is
not a good look anymore oh and I made
sense man because like menudo you age
you aged out of the altar boy business
this dude just grew the [__] up but I
was terrified to go the [__] mess I
forgot
before I went I was like yeah I'm happy
to go my mother told me the night before
I went she was like you know you can't
wear your hat in church right
and I was like Ma
I [__] wear this hat to bed like I
wear this hat in the shower I wear this
hat to [__] like I don't [__] take
off my hat I'm not taking off my hat for
any man she's like you got better take
it off for Jesus and I was like Ma you
don't even go to church anymore and [__]
and she's like I know but you can't wear
your hat in [__] church and I was so
nervous I stayed up all night because I
was like how am I gonna [__] pull
this off and I talked to my wife and I
was just like they want me to take my
hand off the chair she goes the same
institution wants to take away my rights
to [__] have an abortion [__] them
she got very political about it right
away and [__]
so I didn't know what to do because I
didn't want to take my hat off man and
and like number one I got hat head
number two I don't have enough [__]
hair to [__] not wear the goddamn hat
anymore and [__] and we live in the age
of the [__] cell phone and [__] so
when I got to church I was hoping that
we could sit in the back row at least
but instead my mom wants to sit right in
the [__] front row it's Dad's honor
so she was really putting me to the test
though I mean I love my dad but what the
[__] man and so I I go up and I sit in
front before I went up though I gauged
the whole [__] crowd man I was
looking all around and [__] and I didn't
see a single person who would know who
the [__] I was this much I'll say though
is a Thursday morning at 8 30. and you
know people most churches I've been into
in the last [__] 20 years some days
don't even have a big crowd the church
that I used to go to Growing Up used to
have three masses on a Sunday now they
got just [__] one uh membership is is
dropping off this church on a [__]
Sunday on a Thursday at 8 30 had 70
[__] people in the audience damn like
I was like don't you [__] have jobs
like [__] I couldn't believe that
many people went to church there were
three communion lines like three people
like [__] no waiting three [__]
people serving communion and [__] we
didn't have to get up for Community
because we were in the front row because
my mom can't get up or anything and so
the priest comes and brings the
communion right to Mom and stuff like
GrubHub very much yeah it was totally
door dashing it and [__]
um but the kid you know he came to my
mom he served her first uh then he
served my brother and [__] and then he
came to serve me and I was like you know
my training as a young Catholic was like
you can't [__] receive communion if
you haven't gone to Fashion confession
you got sin on your soul and it's been
quite some time and I've done a lot of
[__] sins yeah so I was like I can't
do it but I [__] ate it anyway oh no
you didn't choke I did not choke and my
belly felt good
holy good and [__] um it was a weird
experience though man to be in church
for the first time like in a long time
and while I was sitting there like you
know I remembered like in Dogma we did
the Buddy Christ and part of the joke
was that Jesus on the cross is so
depressing they replaced it with a guy
who's pointing and winking and smiling
[__] the Buddy Christ the [__]
crucifix that they had at this church
was a larger than life-sized Jesus made
of wood on the cross he looked so
[__] pained man and as I sat through
the whole Mass looking at him I just
felt really judged and guilty the whole
[__] time felt so bad man I felt
really kind of depressed and I was
telling my mom all through Mass I was
like doesn't that [__] bum you out
mom and she's like don't curse in church
uh but it was so sweet she held me and
my brother's hand all throughout match
kept reaching over and like grabbing our
hands and stuff like that and they did
say my dad's name out loud like we
celebrate this uh mass in honor of uh
Donald E Smith that's put the E because
my brothers also a Donald Smith right
he's Donald W and [__] and I think my
mom put the East that my brother wasn't
a church and here the priest goal we
celebrate this in honor of Donald Smith
and my [__] brother has a heart
attack or something so [__] but it was
actually kind of kind of sweet man will
I go back again [__] no but it was nice
to go with my mom on this [__] day
and so my mom listens to Hollywood
Babylon every week now ever since she
got [__] sick like she was in the
hospital and she was just like I want to
hear and see your shows so I gave her a
link to Hollywood Babylon and she
listens to it and she she calls you that
Philly boy oh
I said you mean that silly boy she goes
no that Philly boy so since I know my
mother will be listening shout out to
Mom man yep
feel better Grace
you should convert to Judaism
they all wear hats they all wear hats
inside I thought about wearing the hat
but I was like what if they [__] like
call me out on it and [__] I didn't want
to embarrass my mom and [__] with the
priest being like take that [__] off the
giant Jesus comes off the cross and
starts storming you it transforms into a
[__] Jet and takes it
um yeah man it was kind of wild it was
wild being back at church and being the
guy who made Dogma half expected the
ceiling to cave in but it did not happen
yeah which leads me to believe one thing
there's no such thing as God
otherwise good night everybody
we'll leave you on that note
what about you you go to church this
week
I don't have time with all the ball
shaving she goes Jesus man Jesus man
well remembered now I was watching a
show I love on something called me TV
familiar with me TV it's a cable channel
no for those people who still look at
cable but they all they show all their
old reruns classic stuff like Andy
Griffith Show and stuff like that but
they have a show on there called
collector's call that I was actually on
once it's a show that features people
who have vast Collections and they
explore them and you show them different
pieces and then they give you like an
appraisal of your collection so you were
on for your for my Batman collection for
those I'm sure a lot of people follow
the show but if you've never followed
this part of the show Ralph has an
insane Batman collection at his house
he's got a whole [__] I'm a lot of
garmy members in the audience I'm sure
and that's where you do your show every
day right out of the bat cave yeah and
so you've shown it many times and
whatnot but for those who haven't seen
it it's [__] impressive you've got a
deep collection he rolls deep with the
[__] Batman memorabilia so they came
and they did a show on it Lisa welchel's
the host Blair from Facts of Life are
you serious yeah
you met Blair oh did I
showed her the facts of life you know
what I'm saying I see
she takes the good end she takes that
yeah
she's
pretty Catholic or Christian really not
Catholic I thought so but she was Saucy
she was she was she was like show me
your balls
I want to see the scar
no she was salty she was a lot of fun
but um I watched the show beforehand and
it certainly watched it since because
I'm fascinated by people's collections
right so it was a recent episode on that
I was watching this week and the guy has
a collection of only high-end science
fiction fantasy sort of Collectibles
he's got one of Michael J Fox's screen
used hoverboards from Back to the Future
he's got all this stuff and they're
showing this massive collection he says
specifically I only collect high-end
stuff stuff that's really from really
classic movies and stuff so I'm looking
at his collection and I know you like to
mock one of my favorite films
called yoga hosers
no and so they show this guy's
collection and as I'm scanning through
it Josh can you throw the shot up that I
caught in my eye closed holy [__]
[__] out of brazy can we punch in just a
little bit in case anybody misses it
oh my God
Kevin Smith as a diminutive Nazi sausage
man the brazi made it into his
collection that just [__] made my day
right that's what I thought it means he
was the one that saw yoga hosers that's
the guy we've been looking for him for
years
that's [__] up how how were you like
blowing mind blown
that was wild they didn't talk about it
it wasn't you know something they wanted
to feature I mean nobody ever talks
about it so that's true but the fact
that that made it into his collection I
said well there's somebody out there who
liked that thing we did pretty [__]
legit right there holy [__] did you
auction those off no but I I every once
in a while once like we like we've done
stuff at uh the old smog castle where we
would give them away we'd done stuff on
uh edumacation pub quiz back in the day
where that was a prize and stuff so
maybe somebody just took one and sold
one or something well apparently it's a
thing
all the [__] you sold tonight you could
have sold one of those you know I do I
still have some left all right well give
me one yeah what you want one yeah
I'll give you the actual uh Robert
kurtzman who of course is the great uh
special effects guy from knb effects
group he was the one that created Tusk
for us uh he created the brazi suit he
also the I always tease him because he's
the guy that did Marky Mark's dick in
Boogie Nights all right yeah so he's had
a very storied career he did the Golden
goalie too didn't he he did the goal of
Golem as well he did a maquette of uh
the brazi uh the very first one of what
it would look like and stuff so it's
kind of made in in almost wood plastic
finish and stuff
um that's like complete with no outfit
on and it has a little sausage dick as
well so I'll [__] I don't want that
one
that's better than that I don't want to
look at your little dick in my office
that's just that's something why not
yes I've seen it enough
but I just thought it was so cool and
it's the only movie I've ever been with
you where I have lines so I thought I
would you know have a little uh dialogue
in the movie flop yeah well
the first and last time never let Ralph
Garmin talk no you spoke in clerks three
and that movie did well
so maybe that breaks the curse right
there it's there for 12 seconds yes
well that you're the 12 second man
that's all we need you for that's what
Blair from Facts of Life said
all right let's talk to some folks out
here tonight who came particularly long
distances or celebrating special
occasions with us tonight it's our
segment we call the shout outs
[Music]
get your [__] out that one went deep I
almost hit tonsil on that one
that's dear Mike you own it I guess you
felt more comfortable it's my hometown
that's right Scott Horowitz are you here
tonight Scott's right up front Scott
writes Ralph and Kev my wife Marissa has
been talking for a few weeks about
having people over tonight for my
birthday which is Monday the 5th but
then her best friend got her a ticket to
see the new Britney Spears Musical and
she ditched me tonight
there's a Britney Spears Musical
seriously
It's A Cinderella Story
conservatorship story is what it is
I didn't put her in it I'm just saying
she was in one
instead of being stuck home like a loser
alone on Saturday night before my
birthday I decided to be a loser in
public and come to your show solo
nothing better than spending my birthday
with the garmy and the smod family can
you sing happy birthday as Adam West to
me and anyone else whose birthday it may
be
Babble the [__] on Scott well of course
Scott because your your wife doesn't
love you so I would like to I'd like to
give you some
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday Scott Horowitz what I'm
guessing can wear a hat in church
ha
hmm
happy birthday
to you
there you go
[__]
jeez real life director
not a cameraman though no you're
absolutely right obviously uh Harley
Davis are you here Harley
hi Harley Harley's here with her dad
tonight I thought this was so sweet my
name is Harley I'm here with my dad from
Boston we drove down this morning just
for the show thank you so much for
coming down guys uh his birthday is also
on Monday so happy birthday to you too
sir happy birthday
seriously you both have birthdays in the
same week same day these two you guys
should hang out
the only reason we're here is because of
him and all that he does for me I have
never in my whole life thanked him
enough for everything he does for me and
all he does to support and care for me
oh my God I just wanted so wholesome I
know it's so adorable being the dad of a
daughter I just had to read this because
I'll never hear it from my own child
I just want him to know how thankful I
am for him please thank him for being by
my side the best dad in the world and my
best friend I can't promise I will not
date until 18 however but I'll do my
best I love you so much Dad well
congratulations Harley
first of all to Harley and to you Dad
whatever you did you did it right to
have a kid who feels that way about you
and she's not 18 which makes me a little
uncomfortable about tonight's show now
that I think about it how old are you
Harley
oh my [__] god
14. yeah all that stuff he said about
his balls yeah
I'm a Big Bowler Harley I'm a Big Bowler
I
I was in a league back in Philly with
Tommy and the guys and
you got to shave the bowling ball
sometimes
ah the thing about doing Hollywood
babylon's podcast was normally when we
do Hollywood there's an age limit yes
my sphincter's so tight right now
you got to keep it PG-13 the whole night
oh my God we're at a show
yeah 20 minute Babylon
laughs
14.
Harlow you're familiar with the show
though right
yeah
yeah she's heard the podcast
it's a good guy a good dad by the way
yeah letting her kid listen to us at 14
for God's sakes Chris is the best man
but you know we got local laws here in
Atlantic Highlands about corrupting
minors and [__] so you may not be going
back to Hollywood at all
[Music]
here they are
that'd be our highest listen to show
ever yes
who's on it with Silent Bob got arrested
is that how I'd be portrayed in the
media the one guy who was with silence
pretty sure that's what's gonna say on
your gravestone
Muse and I need to unionize
that's right he'll be the other guy yes
uh Chris runt are you in the house Chris
all right
I didn't ask you where you were in the
house just are you in the house location
is everything uh driving down from
Canada
New York what the [__] is that
Josh can you throw that up on the big
screen
Canada
Day what the [__]
how do you say that town
one more time
Cannon
they gotta change that that's
[__] awful
um driving down from New York
and my friend Mike wasn't able to join
me because he just closed on his first
house is he bought a house in Concord
Duncan
[__] he's never getting his mail I'll
tell you that much
uh he couldn't join me because he just
closed on his first house Mike and I
became friends discussing Batman at our
local comic shop so I was hoping Bane
could congratulate Mike on his big
accomplishments
Chris can Bane say some words of
encouragement to Mike on getting his new
house Michael
it's so nice that you bought a house in
kind of
in a place in New York
I I wish you all the best with your
purchase
um make sure you put up a giant crucifix
in your house
it welcomes all people coming in and uh
[Music]
you're right I was having a stroke for a
second
I got lost during a Canandaigua
conundoga there you go there we go all
right yeah
I mean
uh David Collins
all right relax David
at least he said sir that's true uh it
may not be Australia but I think coming
from South Carolina to New Jersey is a
particularly long distance it is sir
thank you so much for making the trip
you came from South Carolina you got you
might be the further other than like
Ralph and Josh and me you may be the
furthest person who traveled to the show
anybody travel further than South
Carolina Miami
laughs
that's the kind of warmth we're looking
for David here at Hollywood Babylon
welcoming South Carolina Warren [__]
Florida
uh well thank you so much for making the
trip David in addition to Live Hollywood
Babylon I'm able to check several items
off my bucket list on this trip hitting
Jay and Bob's secret stash yeah 26 years
in brick and mortar business standing in
front of the quick stop and most
importantly have a drink with Ralph
after the show is that right that's not
gonna happen
no it is if anyone would like to have a
drink with me I know there's a screening
after this a secret screening after this
particular show so I don't want to pull
anyone away from that but if you want to
have a cocktail with me there's a bar
down the street to the right
called the harbor what Harbor Harborside
Grill that's where I'm going to be after
the show I'm gonna go have a glass of
glass of Canandaigua I'm gonna have a
big jar of conundanc
y so I'll see you there David if you
want to have a cocktail
[__] Tusk that's not the movie We're
showing oh so that was really hurtful
yes
and a drive-by [__] insult
um can we tell them what the movie We're
showing is Josh yeah go for it all right
so we're doing a secret screening after
this uh for the folks that want to stick
around we're doing first after this uh
photos uh in the back and once the
photos are done uh we're going to show a
documentary that Dr Josh Roush made tell
them what it is
uh long Lonesome Highway the Michael
Parks documentary yes the story of
Michael Parks our good friend who was in
Tusk the movie you just [__] where I
met him
it's a documentary about Michael Parks
man the great late great Michael Parks
and stuff so it'll be showing right here
in this theater once again when you come
to a [__] smodcast Castle show man
you get five shows that you didn't even
want necessarily that's yes we had an
auction beforehand we're doing a secret
screening afterwards so yeah Kick Back
come watch the movies absolutely
wonderful
what is it
there you go all right oh geez to Josh
and the late great Michael Parks yeah
do we have the Quentin interviews uh no
we're scheduled to have them this summer
so this is the rough cut [__] hey man
so you've seen the documentary before
the Quentin interview is good you've
been waiting for those Quentin
interviews for a goddamn minute so
that's a huge accomplishment to finally
get them because Kevin Smith is
interviewed in the documentary but Kevin
Smith Goes to the opening of a [__]
drawer yes that's true to get Quentin to
talk about Michael Parks which is how I
found Michael Parks in the first place
is a huge score man give it up for Josh
He landed the [__] damn fish
[Applause]
Josh you should just dangle a naked
woman's foot in front of him and he'll
just he'll just show up
he'll find you
you hung out with parks on red state
right what now you hung out with parks
on Redstone that's where we became very
close and uh we chatted a bit during
Tusk as well but it was red State really
where we sort of became close it was
amazing he was amazing uh Katie McGowan
are you here Katie
hi Katie right up front yeah Katie with
that destruction Jersey that you signed
Skeletor Jersey traveling from Detroit
to come see the show thank you so much
[__] farm and that's farther than
South Carolina
David stop fighting that you came the
furthest do we know whether it's further
or not like I would think well by all
means let's stop The Showdown and
[__] Google it
it's got to be further than Miami at
least I don't know
uh brought my cousins Bridget and Laura
long who are locals I would have brought
my mom but I don't think she would like
the show
you're probably right
uh Katie Works in special education she
works with ah the Lord's work adults
adult at special education 18 to 26 so
God you deserve all the love right there
speaking of love she asked could you
have sexy Kevin totally a panty dropper
by the way she is sexy Kevin hook me up
I have the feeling my future soul mate
could very well be in the audience
tonight who else but an HBO fan or
member of the garmy Katie McGowan so can
sexy Kevin extol the virtues of our own
Katie and maybe find her uh would you a
man or a woman what are you looking for
man she wants a man she wants a man okay
we got music we got music hold on we got
music there's music for sexy Kevin you
just spit on it I'm sorry
does it taste like Jack
what's his last name
you're much sharper since you put down
the weed
uh we've always had music for this fair
enough let's hear that music
Oh Oh
Katie you're looking for a man in this
[__] Crowd Oh Jesus let's find one
for you who wants to hook the [__] up
with Katie ladies and gentlemen here in
smodcast Castle you can take empty
theater five
[Music]
and have sex in it and smart Castle
keeper Ernie O'Donnell will have to
clean up after you I don't think that's
what she's looking for clean up in
theater five kids
looking for love in smog Castle you
could totally have it for the low low
price of thirty dollars
rent to theater and be alone with Katie
classy lady over there Katie thank you
for doing the Lord's work that wasn't
very sexy thank you for doing the Lord's
work that's sexy yeah yeah
uh Oren Lev are you here tonight or in
Lev
in the back okay was I born or in Lev
are you a Mandalorian
or in Lev
that is the way
it's carrying baby Yoda back there
that's right uh driving from Norfolk
Virginia
is that closer or further David
no it's not
feels like that's closer right
on the par with that okay uh this will
be my first Babylon live I've always
listened helps me get through my day
especially at my early crappy jobs my
wife Anna on the other hand not a fan
but she did get me the ticket to see you
guys on my birthday so she to abandoned
you on your birthday
man
our wives aren't here let's jerk each
other off
Katie will watch
theater five
and David will judge the distance
[Applause]
look at how far that [__] shot that ain't
farther than South Carolina
[Laughter]
it was legit funny man oh thanks well
I've been doing it for 13 years
so this is full of wives who want their
husbands out of the house I know yes
uh I was wondering if the Germans could
thank her for getting me the ticket and
to let her know about all the fun stuff
she's missing by not listening to the
show herself writes Oren well the
Germans sure they could do that for you
yeah
a good time had by everyone except your
wife or in love
ah yeah Anna very judgy yes we're glad
she's not here tonight yeah because now
you can hook up with this guy right here
in theater five
we'll see you tonight
yeah it's a smartcast Cinemas and
brothel apparently
and your wife is happy to get you out of
the house because she's probably
stopping the neighbor but still
a happy birthday to you here in the in a
place with all the other lonely married
men so you're in companies that's right
it's a total circle jerk place
Daisy chains Galore
nine nine nine Daisy chills
nine guys
this is the way
[Laughter]
I'm more in love I have the foundling we
have to go to this planet
did you ever watch it are you do you
watch it oh yeah yeah are you current
I'm quite caught up I'm done with the
season [__] last episode was
incredible right great do you know who
shot it no same guy that shot clerks
Dave yeah Dave Klein shot that episode
and [__] isn't that crazy I was talking
to Dave about how the show was shot and
they you know a DPS to light an entire
set but in that world sometimes the set
doesn't exist right they'll have green
screen he puts on [__] VR goggles and
then sees the whole [__] set because
they have it pre-loaded and stuff
because they shoot on that big wall the
volume so he's lighting [__] through
[__] VR goggles that aren't even
there and I was like bro like clerks
look like it was shot through a glass of
milk like
why'd you wait so long to get good yeah
I was like how'd you graduate to this
[__] and whatnot it's crazy wow he
showed me a picture of the thing they
they the the set that they shoot on so
the volume is this wall that they load
up the image on and so instead of doing
a green screen there's like a background
that looks so [__] real that he's
like even when you're standing on it and
you know for a fact it's a curved screen
and stuff he's like if you do this with
your eyes it looks like you're in it and
what's amazing about it is where the
camera goes the information moves so it
looks like a real location it's not like
a still picture that just stays in one
place it's like the eyes of one of those
Jesus pictures that follow you [__]
wherever you go it's [__] fascinating
man I mean like how much that [__] costs
it's expensive
no
Star Wars movies are expensive I was
about to Spill and I was like I probably
shouldn't be talking about any of this
and [__] I don't want to lose this job
but yeah it was pretty expensive it's
pretty cool yeah pretty cool he was
there for cool [__] like he was there
when they shot Mark Hamill you know his
[__] when Luke Skywalker came back
before they digitized him yeah yeah well
don't say that but yeah
yeah it's a big secret
24.
he says that Mark comes and does the
performance though like lays out the
performance does all the blocking and
[__] like that it's pretty impressive
you're back on the weed again aren't you
no no okay I just want to make sure all
right a vast G Magnus it's me Kevin
Smith Jason you have you ever wanted to
get lost on the high seas with Jay and
Silent Bob well now you're gonna have
your chance go to Jay and Silent Bob
cruisesque.com right now and sign up for
Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise Askew we're
gonna hit the high seas where we going
Gilligan we're gonna be going to Miami
to Nassau Bahamas on the Norwegian Pearl
doesn't that sound great it's gonna be
me and him it's gonna be all of our
friends we'll be doing live podcasts
there's going to be a movies on board
there's going to be a viewer skew Museum
great times to be had by all ladies and
gentlemen tickets available right now go
buy them man and if you sign up before
June 23rd it's only 100 down per cap and
what are you waiting for man get lost at
sea with Jay and Silent bone let's do it
we also get emails from all around the
world Josh
got an email man
featuring Kevin's reactions that's right
uh Dan Ruiz sent in an email Dan is by
the way in the front row of every show
we do out in Los Angeles for Hollywood
that's right yeah good man he won't come
tonight though did he he didn't come
tonight because that's a lot further
than something I think Mike from Corona
flew out from La though right
flew out from California to come to the
show getting back on a plane after the
show to go back to California are you
serious man you the one that bought the
art piece holy [__] well done and [__]
there's a lot of garmy members right
there in that section so thank you so
much guys we appreciate it what do you
think of New Jersey so far
yeah and
it is the Garden State you're absolutely
right it's right as George Carlin used
to say if you're growing Smoke Stacks
yes
uh Dan writes can you please sing for me
they're coming to take me away ha ha as
Sean Connery well yeah of course Connery
liked to sing a song from time to time
take a little uh audio Josh
remember when you ran away and I got on
my knees and said you're not to leave
because I'd go but a shark well you left
me anyhow and then the days got worse
and worse and now you see I've gone
completely out of my mind and they're
coming to take me away they're coming to
take me away
to the funny farm well life is beautiful
all the time and I'll be happy to see
those nice young men in that clean white
Coach they're coming to take me away
pushy Galore
there you go
[Applause]
if also folks also email us towns they
run across in their travels that have
[__] up names we never bothered to
name this segment so we call it your
Town's got a [__] up name
[Music]
Sean goody sent this one in instead of
one town he mapped out for us a trip
that he says you and I should take
together a road trip here's the map of
the trip
it's in the UK we start we start in [__]
we head down to [__] Bridge we stop in
dick place there in Scotland then on to
cockermouth Cocker mouth then to penis
Stone short hop to [__] alley
to [__] whole Lane
stop by fingering hoe
quick stop off in ass Hill and then we
end the trip in shitterton
sounds like the next Babylon tour I
think so we'll see you on there
I'd like to see the concert tees
the list of all the names on the back
cockerton
folks off officer
cannondagua
folks also send us emails about stuff
that's meant for kids things that
children are supposed to enjoy but when
you take a look at them you realize
they're inappropriate toys
what the [__] is that inappropriate boys
starting off this email from Ray
polakowski this is candy kids should be
safe to have candy Harley should 14 she
should be able to buy some candy without
being exposed to this kind of
advertisement I should bring it back to
the [__] youngster man or we're just
getting comfortable and suddenly ties
into the inappropriateness of this show
for kids and this for kids this candy
nobody needs creamed filled beavers
quite the contrary everybody needs cream
filled seems inappropriate
because beavers Harley are animals that
should be left alone and not pumped full
of candy cream
I'm not going to be able to relax all
night I'm not it's on my mind I'm sorry
calling it candy cream made even dirtier
for some reason we want some of my candy
cream
no
Canadian geek pool sent this he says
although the book itself is not
inappropriate people who work in a
library especially in the children's
section need to be aware of where they
put the labels on the books for the
library scan codes
laughs
[Laughter]
so you're leaving things open to
interpretation there it's a great
[__] title man let's [__] the duck
let's not not for children it's not
that's my point
and this comes from eres kariel in
Israel wow is that far enough for you
Dave
you'll allow it all right
that's true you're still the king he
lives in uh Tel Aviv and he says
Israel's oldest shopping mall there is
called the disengoff center and they
have an entire playground just for kids
and the most famous and popular part of
the playground is the giant elephant in
the center of the playground I got a
picture of it here this is the
playground that's the elephant all the
kids get to climb up and go into the
mouth of the elephant and play around
now how do the kids get out of the
elephant do you think Kevin
the traditional way how else would you
get out of the elephant there you go
holy [__]
oh that's a way to get into the elephant
as well
it looks like his giant red thing that
he's dragging behind him his lipstick
prolapsed anus
it's one of them weight lifters
we'd also say goodbye to folks from the
entertainment business who gave us many
years of entertainment and left us too
soon we call those our Tinseltown stiffs
and now another edition of
[Music]
will be oscar-winning editor Glenn Farr
passed away this week at the age of 77.
one is Oscar for the work on the right
stuff the motion picture about the Space
Program absolutely amazing movie
brilliant film he later went on to host
30 episodes excuse me edit 30 episodes
of The Mentalist so having an Oscar
doesn't necessarily guarantee that
you're going to work in show business
but he kept going
and he's dead
this is
just saying you wouldn't ask for the
right stuff you think you know you're
like oh my God he's going to do amazing
[__] forever exactly as a critique on
the mentalism yes phone shade it was a
fine show but still but know the right
stuff exactly bummer uh Milt Larson
passed away folks in Southern California
may know that name he was the founder of
the Magic Castle oh [__] man not far
from where you live there it's actually
down the hill from where I live the
Magic Castle is this place where you
can't I've lived near it for 21 years 22
years and I've never been in it because
you have to wear pants
and I mean long pants long pants not
like I tried to get into George and they
were like no you got to go home and get
pants I was like I don't own pants and
like well you're not coming into the
Magic cast it's got a very strict dress
very strict dress code but uh Paul Deany
uh co-creator of Harley Quinn
um he's a member so he was always
getting my daughter Harley in and my
wife Jen has gone but I've never got to
go have you been in the magic house I
have in fact it's uh it's a society of
magicians that has a private club and
and a restaurant there and you have to
be invited by a member in order to go
and it's very ornate and it's got lots
of secret passageways and things and
they'd perform magic there and so this
guy started in 1963 with his brother and
it's still a a very popular spot in Los
Angeles today he died at the age of 92
this week oh that's magic right there
and yeah it is or did he die
he disappeared that was it yes oh that's
a bummer man and character a big [__]
life long life yeah for sure yeah to run
a castle that has people doing magic in
it yeah
it's not my life but it's a life
uh Sergio called her own character actor
passed away at the age of 77. he was um
popular from his roles in at World's End
the Pirates of the Caribbean movie
played Captain Villa Nueva in that and
best known by movie theater audiences
perhaps as Jose in Men In Black you may
remember this scene here is the work of
the late Sergio Calderon
looks like he fell off the bus in the
wrong part of town amigo
in fact I'm going to bet dollars to pay
so you're not from anywhere near here
[Music]
Mikey
yeah
Mikey when they let you out of jail
political Refugee right yeah I mean the
treaties you just violated
one try seven
he was the head on the stick not the guy
in the uh
well that's how most people know him
rest in peace we look at actors in film
and television shows and realize that
not every actor gives a great
performance but if the if the
performance is bad enough it can go all
the way around to become Exquisite
acting
[Music]
Ralph Garman and Kevin Smith
um this one comes from manbat33 he said
I always thought this clip of James
Woods from The Specialist would be
perfect for Exquisite acting well Woods
is good he's an Exquisite actor under
the best of circumstances here he is
getting very angry at Sylvester Stallone
on the phone it truly is exquisite
you got no [__] loyalty
and you got no code listen to me you son
of a [__] time's up 58 seconds right
right
guys
what do you look at
turn around
laughs
[Applause]
I found out everyone in that room voted
for Biden that's how that that's where
he pulled it that's where he pulled it
from and lastly we look for mistakes
things boners bloopers Goofs gaffs
whatever you call them it's mistakes
made in television and film that someone
should have caught but they didn't we
did though there's [__] that should not
be
[Music]
here's some [__] that should not be
Armando ronquillo sent this one in [__]
that should not be round
you want to smell it no no
forever 14 years old
Kevin and Ralph because of you guys I'm
always looking out for that extra that
gives a little extra in a scene I was
just watching the first season of The
Sopranos and notice this lady in the
purple dress having a lot of fun at this
wedding scene thanks for the free funny
Armando here it is from season one of
Sopranos [__] that should not be
laughs
look at the rapturous eyes rolled back
in her head
who doesn't call cut on that scene
can we get the girl in the purple dress
out of the scene please
print that take
we also take a look at all the
entertainment news for the week in a
segment we call the HBO headlines
[Music]
Al Pacino in the news this week
83 year old Al Pacino was that old now
yes wow surprised apparently that his 29
year old girlfriend nor alfala is
pregnant with his child
so 29 is almost 30 and he's 83 so that's
50 54 year difference indeed
Oh indeed
oh
I gotta tell you
I had no idea
that my sperm could still swim
I thought they had those life rafts on
those those
Lifesavers they throw out on a ship
I didn't know they could swim
I got a picture of joke what's that so
uh you know what uh he said to her egg
apparently
to her egg I said say hello to my little
friends
it's a writer's strike dude I don't know
if you can do it [__] tell anybody I
wrote the joke
writer's Guild will come after me uh
Nora alfala by the way 29 years old
previously had a relationship with Mick
Jagger before uh Al so she has a she has
a type yeah
[Laughter]
um Al was so surprised it says in this
article how surprised was he he was so
surprised that he had her take a DNA
test to prove that it was actually his
baby because he didn't believe that he
was capable of impregnating a woman due
to medical issues now that'll make a
woman fall in love with you I thought so
too
uh listen up
my penis does not work
so for you to be pregnant
I'll tear this whole place down with my
penis like a fire
thing that shoots
but the opposite
I think he's just jealous because De
Niro's having a kid and he wanted to
one-up him De Niro's also having a kid
yes
the old fathers
I'm gonna file that one myself the old
fathers Arnold Schwarzenegger
congratulations to him he's got a new TV
series and it's at the top of the
Netflix TV list
Fubar is the name of the series have you
seen any of Fubar I saw a billboard for
it in Los Angeles but I haven't seen the
shows it's doing well it is number one
on the Netflix list in all the
English-speaking countries in 90
different countries it broke the top ten
people are watching he's still a star
you can't you can't deny it
I think aparna is in that aparna who's
in jail and Bob reboot with us
um I have seen one episode of it and I
I'm good
I wonder what that show would sound like
ah it's a fuba you know which means
14 up beyond all recognition
well remembered
it's like every fourth joke you remember
there's a 14 year old in the crowd it's
hard
speaking of things appropriate for 14
year olds little mermaids in the news oh
the Disney film the makeup artist who
did the special effects makeup for the
character of Ursula played by Melissa
McCarthy is under Fire from the lgbtq
community
because they say Melissa McCarthy's
character was inspired by the drag queen
Divine
in the in the original in the original
and also in this one as well so they
believe that an lgbtq
makeup artist should have been hired to
do that makeup
someone just farted
uh the man who did it is named Peter
King and he is an old seasoned makeup
artist and he is very personally
offended by the uh by the criticism
because he did Lord of the Rings and
Star Wars Episode the eight The Last
Jedi and Spider-Man and he feels like if
if I can do the job I know I'm old he
said so that's fine but he feels like he
should be able to do the job nonetheless
and I feel I feel that's that's true I
think he's you should be able to hire
people on their Merit without getting
too too political about it yeah I
thought it was going to be like they
thought somebody from the lgbtq
community should have played the part or
something like that but you would think
that would be more of a complaint than
the guy's doing the makeup the makeup
yeah that seems a little deep cut I feel
bad for old white guys
speaking of old white guys another old
white guy in the news getting a hard
time Ryan Gosling that old [__]
why is he having a hard people are
complaining he's too old to play Ken in
the new Barbie movie are you are you
[__] me have you seems legit funny
isn't that true have you seen hashtag
not my Ken have you seen that no on
social media oh my God what a divisive
world we live in people are just begging
to be [__] pissed off about something
truly uh yeah
he looks great he looks fine I'm on the
look he's just [__] Ryan Gosling's
too old
and we're [__] right
uh yeah apparently people are saying
he's too old to play the character and
he was interviewed in GQ at least he has
a sense of humor about it and he said
it's kind of funny this clutching your
Pearl's idea of not my Ken have you ever
thought about Ken before this he asked
people
like you cared about Ken this whole time
you never cared Barbie never [__] with
Ken that's the point if you ever really
cared about Ken you would know that
nobody cared about Ken he said
so your hypocrisy is exposed that's why
his story must be told
[Music]
[__] hate it can't have it all I know
right pretty and funny and Canadian the
third thing well that's why he's nice
yeah Taylor Swift is the second richest
female in music this week Forbes
Magazine just released their music list
and she is at the number two spot her
net worth is 740 million dollars Jesus
she is second behind Rihanna who doubles
her worth at 1.4 billion dollars are you
serious she has a makeup line a cosmetic
line that apparently does very well and
that's where she makes a ton of her
money but uh Taylor Swift is the middle
of a tour right now called the eras tour
and that tour is expected to gross 1.6
billion so they're expecting she will
shoot to number one at some point geez
man I apologize somebody needs an
umbrella Ella Ella I apologize to all
the Taylor Swift jokes I ever made about
her I know give me some money now you
could get a [__] loan from her
exactly did you hear that uh Bill
Cosby's being sued civilly for a sexual
assault in 1969.
I don't want to touch that but it's I'm
glad I this is the only way you can get
this guy he got out of prison so you
have to sue him into the poor house now
at this point I think everyone should
come forward
because I am the worst person in the
world
I would see that in a while I know you
haven't because I'm awful
when people are awful they'll stop doing
impressions with them you see
that was a staple of early battle it was
until we knew he was a [__] Criminal
and Billy Joel's in the news this week
good old BJ he is
uh ending his Madison Square Garden
residency
after 150 shows yeah he's been doing it
how many years now uh he started in 2013
that's when MSG is a full decade first
ever music franchise began and he is
doing 10 final concerts they start on
the October 20th of this year and then
that'll be it he has been doing monthly
shows at Madison Square concert excuse
me Madison Square Garden for we sold 1.6
million tickets and all that time yeah
um I saw him a couple months ago in Los
Angeles at the Sofi stadium and he puts
on an amazing [__] show and he's 70 I
think but just uh just brilliant just
great stuff [__] Piano Man he's a
local not local Jersey but out here he's
close enough Long Island right indeed
yeah
is that Billy South Carolina so shut the
[__] up
I got you
and lastly Justin Bieber's in the news
Justin Bieber
nobody
wanna know why I'll tell you why
that's right
it's still [__] place it really does
really
people really like to come in for that
you're a little runt by the way they
said Haley he's a little guy he's just
he's not tall you little runt you're so
tiny
really embarrasses him when people say
that
uh Bieber's in the news we talked about
this last year I think when he partnered
up with Vespa scooters for me with the
Vespa I know the scooter but I didn't
know he partnered up we talked about
this uh at a Babel show last year he was
designing his own Vespa Scooter in
conjunction with the company and they
were talking about the pre-order at the
time if you wanted one of the special
Justin Bieber Edition Vespas you had to
order right then because they were going
to be gone and sell out and they're not
available after that so get on it
there's plenty of them left
[Laughter]
if you wanted to buy one today you could
just get one they're starting to be
delivered now that the pre-orders uh are
over they just arrived here in the
United States and boy are they not
something
here's here's Justin Bieber uh on his
specially designed Vespa
so it looks like a regular Vespa it's
white but at least it's got white
writing on it it says Justin Bieber and
some flames it's wider than him look at
how white that is
he looks like the great kazoo in that
helmet
Remember The Flintstones
oh
watch me ride my best bar
uh they're not flying off the floor
that's what I'm trying what do they cost
how much they start at five grand if you
wanted everything with all the bells and
whistles and get up to eight nine grand
for a Vespa [__] hey man you can get
a regular one for about half the price
but
it's better
Bieber Bieber when asked about the Vespa
said I'll let you I'll let you read what
he said because I know you do you do
Justin the first time I wrote a Vespa
was somewhere in Europe that makes sense
probably either London or Paris I just
remember seeing a Vespa and being like I
want to ride one of those
so articulate yeah when talking about
designing it he's saying being able to
express myself whether it's through ART
music or visuals be able to create
something from nothing is part of me you
didn't create something from nothing you
painted a Vespa white that's what you
did yep
bad guy
reinvented the wheel person
we got some geek news you want to talk
about that let's hit it
big news
I've had enough of this uh writer strike
can you talk to your friends and make
this all go away good try man they're
they're can you build a bridge between
the two sides so we can all get going I
can't I tried they uh feel like it's
going to go until at least September
maybe October oh my God yeah uh speaking
of which as an aside did you see this
week that Jennifer Lopez's new movie got
shut down because the writers Were
Striking what was it what's the movie
it's it's why I love it it's called
Unstoppable
oh
how ironic man holy [__] I love that I
love that story but the sad news is
another really hurt me in the nads here
uh Tom Holland says Spider-Man 4 is now
on hold because of the writer's strike
they were in meetings they were talking
about early plot points and now the
whole thing is put on the back burner
because of the writers strike so who
knows when we're going to see Spider-Man
4. come on now it's a crime don't [__]
with spiders that's what I'm saying good
God great power comes great whatever
right
I've seen uh across the spider version I
have not it's I've been uh flying here I
watched a little of it tonight [__]
astounding I didn't watch the whole
thing because the first one was genius
this looks fantastic looks like a
goddamn work of art and stuff
um and apparently it's now like gonna
open it's the highest grossing opener of
2023 and I think it's the highest
grossing Spider-Man opener of the entire
franchise
as well it's [__] huge the number
that they open to this weekend which I
think is like 113 or 114. it's three
times what the original uh into the
spider-verse opened at wow yeah huge
massive
I know I was gonna say animation yeah
um The Flash coming out uh what's the
next week that's right we're gonna be
doing not next week it's uh January uh
January June 15th is the Thursday night
that it opens but it officially opens
June 16th
um we're doing a watch with Kev right
here at smodcast and watch it with me we
charge you five bucks more to watch it
with me and then I do a q a for a movie
I had nothing to do with whatsoever
um so that'll be happening but I get to
see it before him I was bitching about
like they've been having screenings for
like Stephen King and the Russo brothers
and I was like why not me and they're
like because you're not as successful as
them idiot no it makes sense but I made
enough noise that I got invited to the
premiere no yeah so on June 12th which
is Jason Muse's birthday uh we're both
getting to go to see uh the flash I
think that had something to do with Ben
more than anything else or on Ben's list
because he's also in the movie would
that be Affleck that would be us oh I
got you okay I didn't mean to drop a
name so hard but yes but yeah man I'm
gonna be there at the premiere so I'll
let you know how it goes Muse is going
to feel so bad when you tell him he
can't go because you're taking me
how are you going to explain that yeah
Zone invite man yeah I can potentially
bring you you want to go I could
potentially bring you we'll auction it
off to you how much is it worth
yes begins with begins and ends with
anal speaking of flash they asked the
director Andy muschetti yeah if there is
a sequel would he still work with Ezra
Miller and he said if a sequel happens
yes I don't think there's anyone that
can play that character as well as they
did he said somewhere Grant Gustin is
like oh really hold my beer it's gonna
say there have been other actors that
weren't
um I don't know didn't have charges of
felony burglary or choke a woman to the
ground in Iceland or harass a couple in
Hawaii and break into their home and
also just by like long term nothing
against Ezra or whatever but like Grant
Gustin played the part for nine [__]
years yeah you would imagine he's got a
lot more practice than the person who
played the character what four times or
something I would just I'd like to
believe that the film could survive a
recasting if and I know that Ezra is
attempting to address their problems and
getting getting help and mental health
issues and stuff and I'm hoping that
that is all real and true and that they
do get better but
um I don't think it's necessary that you
have to keep them in the role the only
thing necessary for a sequel is Bring
Back Michael Keaton that's true that's
why everybody wants to go yeah good
heavens
all right before we say good night folks
we got one last bit of business to take
care of and that's to take a look at
Liam Neeson's
arm
no I'm sorry Haley
Harley
cover your ears
uh Liam Neeson famously is one of the
biggest uh
yeah let's see you walk this minefield
one of the biggest penises in Hollywood
we all know what a penis is that somehow
sounds dirtier yeah I know
one of the biggest [__] in Hollywood
own it man own that [__] get your mouth
around that cop all right easy
and folks every week send us in fact
send us in facts about it at HBO podcast
aol.com if you want to email us anything
about the show that's the place to go
here are this week's five facts about
Liam Neeson's [__]
[Music]
Ros is
that's right people now singing along in
a foreign language
it's very strange Liam Neeson's [__] is
so big
[Applause]
it gives Apache Chief penis envy
do you remember Apache Chief from uh
from Super Friends I mean that's
that's big deep cut right there although
since I look under his skirt there I
don't really see much hanging so maybe
it's not a big deal Liam Neeson's [__]
is so big
he needs a squadron of drones to
manscape
nice and on brand yeah no extra charge
manscape.com
a leonie's [__] is so big
when Liam gets hard it raises the debt
ceiling
political very political Liam niece's
[__] is so big
it extends through the entire
spider-verse
certainly goes across it for sure and
lastly when Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
[Applause]
President Biden tripped over it
ladies and gentlemen of smart Castle
have you had a good time this evening
thank you so much for welcoming me back
to Jersey I appreciate it thanks for
being here kids but there would be no
show without the guy sitting to my left
giving up the legendary the one the only
route [__] Garmin
let's hear it from my bestest buddy and
Babel brother the owner of this joint Mr
Kevin Smith
and that is Hollywood Babylon for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph of the
[__] off good night Atlanta College
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]